I said to blood work over the weekend in love and inflammation markers are
and people getting higher. Do you have any suggestions by CA 15 3196 points in
two weeks in the in the CA 2729 went down to 99 points in two weeks. I said the
results of the PET scan also. This is the first one so it's a baseline. Can cancer
diop cause inflammation? Try to sort things out. So what could cause inflammation?
A person's doing mistletoe therapy that could cause inflammation. If you have
a lot of diop that certainly can cause inflammation because diop will produce
endotoxins that you have to deal with. If you have another another there's other
possible reasons for inflammatory processes and what's typical if you're as
and gives person indication that they're inflammatory markers. A C-reactive
protein. So C-reactive protein CRP is really is a measurement of breakdown of
inflammatory cytokines. So it tells you that there's some inflammatory process
going on which can be that can be a good thing. It can be so remember initial
inflammatory processes are an immune reaction. So it can be an immune reaction. Your
body is actually working cancer. That's why something that's like mistletoe therapy
that's going to stimulate a strong immune reaction can cause increase in
inflammatory processes.